hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so straight up
talking about this and he's he's got the
basic idea now that okay we're
interested in consequences of pinyon
consequences of pleasure the propensity
to lead to pain is negative utility the
propensity to pleasure is positive
utility these can cancel each other out
so something is particularly painful but
also particularly pleasurable it can act
like a zero or neutral value overall you
can add pleasures up and if you had more
pleasures in it becomes better you can
take pleasures away becomes worse
likewise the pains you can add more
pains it becomes worse you can take
pains away and it becomes better so how
do we do this in sort of real-life
situations
well Bentham says there's four main
things that you can look at first off
right off the bat with any pain or
pleasure and one of them is what he's
going to call intensity or you know its
value so let's use the term
and what you have to be able to do with
this is give the give the pain or the
pleasure a number value let's just keep
it really simple and we'll say we can
give it from one to ten because I think
you guys are used to doing that you know
rating things in terms of one to ten or
you know one start of five stars or
something like that let's do the
wunderkind how many of you have been in
not necessarily the hospital but maybe a
clinic or well those of you already
happens you know you got hurt and you
got a trainer come up to you and one of
the things that you ask you is well Kate
your pain on a scale from one to ten
what is that pain you say well it's an
eight you don't it being really bad it's
it's kind of hard to figure out isn't it
but the more that you thought about it
if you if you got into a lot of
situations like that do you think it
could better with rating these sorts of
things probably and you know you could
probably look at people in pain and we
show pain differently I know you know
some of us are more stoic some of us are
kind of whiskey's about it but you can
look at a person you can you can say
yeah they're in a lot of pain they're in
there in less pain you can rate them
against each other
so one of the numbers that we have to
come up with is is the intensity
what about pleasures if I gave you an
assignment which I'm not going to do
give you enough assignments if I gave
you an assignment to sort of take all
the pleasures in your life and put them
into a scale and rank them in relation
to each other
it would be tough I think for some of
them but could you do it would you be
able to do it if yet you know a little
bit of time on your hands like you know
let's say we take a few examples what
kind of candy do you guess like
Twizzlers okay the rest would be like
not the black
a lot of people like black licorice
including me so eating a twizzler a
single twizzler when you usually eat
whispers and go to the movies okay now
you have a single twist learn you have
going to the movies and I understand it
would really depend on a lot of
circumstances like is it a good movie is
it a bad movie let's say it's um good
yeah and it's in a nice theater so you
know no feet sticking to the floor like
that your seat is actually comfortable
not a lot of people talking while you're
watching the movie nobody sitting in
front of you with a hat so we've got a
very small level of pleasure movie
what's a big pleasure something you
really really enjoy something that
motivates your life
I was spending time with the people that
you liked the most
all of you have some friends or some
family that you like the most right your
top three people only those people none
of the people that bother you you know I
understand sometimes if you want to be
involved with some of the people you
like you got to be involved people if
you don't like to let's say that's not
the case so we've got like three
different levels what number would you
give to the single twisper it's Reverend
Johnson maybe you want right if you gave
somebody a whole bag of Twizzlers maybe
there would be a two maybe you know
single twizzler is one and then you add
another one it's not as good as the
first one right Candy's never it is but
you know more you know the first taste
is better than all the rest number would
you give to the being together with all
your friends stay for a long time
nothing happens on the horizon keeping
you from spending time 8 9 what would
you give it 10 to there anything you
could give a 10 - if you're a drug
addict you'd give that probably that
drug is there anything else I could
compare to that what's worth thinking of
it what about the middle thing that the
movie seeing a really good movie what
number would you give it can't be a 1
can't be a 8 or 9 what would you give
six-five
how many would give it a four
nobody I'm gonna give it a five
completely give it a sense so it looks
like six is probably worth maybe maybe
we'd give it a five point five right you
can you can do a decimal scale it's the
next thing that comes up that would
affect this would be a duration how long
does the pleasure last now let's think
about the twizzler thing again how long
is the pleasure of eating a single
licorice twizzler feasibly last I mean
you could probably make it last a long
time absolutely had to you know if you
were in prison and you only got that one
twizzle or once a day you would probably
save but you know realistically speaking
how about how much time you think that
twizzler is giving you pleasure yeah
how long do you think I might take I
mean we could we could actually
objectively measure this we could put
people down get much was learned just
watch them maybe a minute two minutes
not even there that's better
I mean somebody might nurse it along for
half an hour that's there they're really
getting into that twizzler that the
moment you know how long it is is there
is there enjoyment after the movie to
you think yeah because you remember it
and so you sit down and remember that
really good twizzler that you had from
you could what about the being together
with good friends that could last your
whole life or it could be a weekend I
mean you would would it be better to
spend time with your friends over entire
week or just a weekend you would rather
have a weekend rather than a week with
ah yeah that well then you would be
introducing some other considerations
which will come to so duration are
important what else
probability or a certainty this is an
interesting one if you go and get
yourself a pack of Twizzlers could there
be something wrong with the pack could
you know something have gotten into the
mix and it doesn't taste like cherry or
strawberry I think that's what the red
ones taste like more or less right and
instead tastes like spinach that could
happen not pretty likely
oh is it or they mixed it up and it's
got the black licorice flavor I'm going
to be like black licorice anybody in
your life how many of you find it
disgusting ok so there there's a small
tiny possibility that that red licorice
actually has black licorice in it they
just change the coloring but it's not
very likely at all
now that's thing about a movie you
haven't actually seen the movie you've
heard that it's good you know that
movies have a certain genre you like to
manage you know some of the stars in the
movie and they're people that you enjoy
watching is it would you give a 99%
probability to being a good one good 80%
60% what would you give it's it's hard
to tell isn't it you'd have to pick some
number though in order to make this work
now the spending time with your friends
yeah maybe if maybe if you were going to
spend time to them for a week maybe
there is a chance
yeah so so maybe actually the weekend
with a shorter duration but a higher
certainty in enjoyment is the better bet
maybe that has a higher total utility
the other thing that he talks about is
which I'm not gonna talk much about is
what you call propinquity or nearness
and Bentham thinks that we should prefer
pleasures that are close by we should
give them a higher rating than we do
pleasures that are far off likewise with
paints that's that's a bit debatable and
I'm not gonna worry about but I put it
up there for consistency sake he talks
about two other things two attacks about
purity and fecundity but what those
really boil down to the purity of the
pleasure is the light that is the degree
to which that pleasure is not
accompanied by other pains so you know
to use the example of eating too much
it's funny too much right at least while
you're doing the eating but typically
it's it's a mixed pleasure right because
your your stomach's gonna hurt
afterwards and you might feel sluggish
or you might actually feel upset with
yourself for eating so much right losing
your temper might be pleasurable at
first but it brings about pains and even
anger is a mixed pain and pleasure at
the same time but company is that
likelihood producing further pleasures
if you did get together with your
friends for a weekend that's Pleasant by
itself let's say your friends are pretty
smart people do you think more pleasant
things might come out of it like
opportunities to get together again well
that would be fecundity but you can
treat that as a separate pleasure or
pain the other thing that really matters
is expect
if you want to determine whether a given
action a given policy a given you know
way of doing things is the right thing
to do or not you not only have to look
at how much pleasure or pain is
generated you know with all these
factors you have to look at how many
people are effective so if you could for
example this is kind of silly one but
let's say you could give a million
people a bag of Twizzlers one said these
are a million people in the third world
so a lot of these people you know don't
get to us very often and you know may
not even have eaten that day probably
giving him sugar straight sugar it's
nothing the right thing to do but let's
say they'd enjoy it right you could give
a million people Twizzlers and each one
you know have a fairly small intensity
of pleasure it wouldn't go on for an
awful long time but you can be pretty
sure they'd be happy with it there'd be
some people let's say 99% supposing we
saw a person
I don't want Twizzlers I wanted skittles
and then you know where's the pleasure
it's right right in front of that meal
let's say we impose that to in order to
for the twizzler company to give you
these million bags of Twizzlers they say
that you need to poison some random
stranger not kill just make them real
sick for like a week
like gut-wrenchingly sick now that's a
pretty intense pain right and it goes on
for a week that's a lot longer than the
pleasure coming from the bag of
Twizzlers and let's say that the
whatever it is that you're going to give
them it's a hundred percent guaranteed
to make it sick so you know really good
certainty they're gonna get sick right
away and now here's where the extent
comes in one person they're gonna be in
a lot of pain they're not going to be
very happy
about this and maybe some other paints
come out too they have to miss work so
you know that causes some other hassles
there our spouse thinks that they're
literally belly aching about nothing
because they don't know that they've
been poisoned we know we can draw all
sorts of things but it's a million
people as opposed to one and you're
making each of those million people a
little bit happier you're only making
one person miserable
wouldn't that balance it wouldn't all
that pleasure for that extent of people
balance out that they're in a long run
small amount of pain that you're giving
to that other person if you say yes to
that you're a utilitarian if you say no
to that it's probably because you think
there's something off about that and you
you may be able to put your finger on it
right now or you may not be but if you
say no to that
you're not a utilitarian you're
something else if you think that it's
wrong to poison one person and produce
some pain for them even though it would
produce an awful lot of pleasure way
more pleasure than pain from a great
extent of people then you have some
other basis on that you're making your
decisions that they will explore those
as the semester goes on let's say you
are in the toilet area how do you
calculate this out well for any given
action you have to look at the pains and
pleasures that would be created by it so
let's say there is one pleasure one pain
will make it really really simple and it
effects five people you have to tally up
with that pleasure would be each of
these things and you can you know you
can multiply them
the intensity by the duration by the
certainty by the nearness and come up
with some number coming up with the
numbers it's kind of tricky but you know
you can figure it out as you go along
and then you have to multiply it by the
number of people who are actually
affected by it so look let's change a
little bit now we have five people will
use the classic trolley problem are you
guys familiar with this one so there's a
trolley this is seven a lot of different
ways there's a trolley and it's running
along and there are there's the phrasing
of a bunch of different ways I'm gonna
choose this one there are five people on
the trolley and if the trolley goes off
the course these people are gonna die
it's going really really fast faster
than trolley should go thank you
boy there's somebody on the tracks and
if the trolley keeps on going it's gonna
flatten that person kill them on the
spot you're in control of the trolley
you have a lever that will actually send
the trolley going in a different
direction would you do it
or would you allow that one person to
die I mean think about this if you
actually sent it off the tracks I'm
actually changing the thing a little bit
to make it a bit more extreme you'd be
hurting more people wouldn't you but you
would deal if you let it go on you'd be
allowing a person to be hurt kill and
that could have repercussions that could
affect their family other people maybe
as people are watching them oh my god
this awful thing happened today so it
could create a lot of pain but it
wouldn't create as much pain because of
the extent a utilitarian is going to
take the greater number usually and
translate them lifeboat problems are
similar to if you have a lifeboat and
you can only save so many people there's
actually two lifeboat problems who you
save first of all and then do you you
know
if other people want to come on board
but it creates the chance of the
lifeboats going to sink to you love
where you to push them away well that
has to do with calculating outcomes
calculating pains and pleasures that are
likely for something if you could save
let's say we make a life one thing you
got 20 people in the lifeboat and
there's somebody who's trying to get on
board and if that person gets on board
that lifeboat is likely to capsize not
guaranteed but likely you're the only
person who's actually well enough to
keep them from getting on board to hit
them with the or well utilitarian would
probably say yes because again the
greater the greater extent is going to
outweigh a lot of this stuff but this is
what you would have to do you have to
figure out each pain and pleasure caused
by this action and then figure out how
many people it applies to and then come
up with a total for that and then you'd
have to look at the alternate
possibilities the alternate actions that
could be taken and what the pains and
pleasures caused for them would be and
you telling Gosa so that's you know when
I when I've been given to this work
worksheet that workshop worksheet is a
way to do that fairly easily if you were
going to do this there might only be two
pains and pleasures involved there might
be more than fits on the worksheet you
know and it does require you to come up
with some sort of numbers which is one
of the tricky things about
utilitarianism one way you could come up
with numbers is to look at all these
things in terms of dollar values how
much would you pay for a given pleasure
if you if you had a completely rational
universe then what you pay for a
particular pleasure would what seem to
fit that if a pleasure is worth $50 it
must be 50 times as good as a pleasure
that you get a dollar for pains how much
would how much pain how much would a
person have to pay you to endure a
certain kind of pain you could carry
something on like that yeah yeah that's
that's one of the that is one of the
issues with this Bentham is is assuming
that people are more or less similar
when it comes to this kind of traffic
that maybe you could deal with it by
averaging it out or something that is a
problem with utilitarian calculation
there's a lot when you start probing
this there's a lot of things that could
go wrong with this moral theory but on
the surface which is what I'm trying to
present to you here it looks pretty
straightforward doesn't it it looks like
you can reduce morality down to a bunch
of calculations so let's take a concrete
example
let's take a really simple how many of
you have a brothers and sisters
almost all is it fair for a parent most
of you don't have brothers and sisters
yeah I mean you've got cousins to begin
this word is it fair for a parent to
favor one child systematically over the
other children because you know it could
be because that child needs more it
could be because they want to go board
that child for doing better let's make
it really simple we'll put it just in
terms of affection not like material
support or something like that so this
will be our problem to favor one child
how many children should we have just
two children or three children three
okay so one child with much more
affection and you know if you want to
come up with reasons why they just
happen to like that kid more now what
does your gut tell you about this right
off the bat is it is it could you make
the case that this could be a good thing
or at least a permissible thing what do
you think it's wrong
how many of you think it's wrong is
there anybody who thinks that you know
they're the parent they get to decide it
since their house there wouldn't be
anything wrong nobody why do you feel
that it would be wrong what is it going
from you've got not necessarily doing
Bentham's calculation why does it strike
you as being wrong I think you're right
why do you think it's wrong
sure you have some sense do you have to
explain this to somebody else you're
sitting here now you're an adult and you
you know you're your brother or sister
or brother and sister-in-laws doing this
sort of thing and you're you're actually
saying hey you know that isn't right
what would you say to them okay that's a
good one
so consequences for the favorite child
right okay so outside of the immediate
situation yeah we'll come back to that
it's a really good consideration there
why else do you think yeah the children
don't deserve the same love and
affection so there's a question of
equally and you know how we often talk
about this we would say that that's not
fair
right that's that's one of our basic
moral concepts is fairness
yeah yeah good so good produces conflict
let's take the immediate situation how
do the kids that are being not favored
how they feel in the present okay so
some of the kids feel they huh and I
think this would be a separate
consideration they may screw up in the
presence put it in those terms okay so
be a book a lot of stuff here
to work with you notice when you're put
on the spot to think in moral terms you
guys can pretty well you feel a little
reticent about it at first but once once
we get the ball rolling a lot of
different considerations come up now
could we think of these in terms of
pains and pleasures consequences good
consequences bad consequences some of
these definitely we can do right for the
present right so let's say we think
about the pain that the kids feel the
ones who are being treated too happy in
the presence but I'm not actually gonna
put all the stuff about intensity and
all that up in the board let's just see
if we can come up with a raw number
we'll pull it out of the air how bad is
it
what's it is a constant practice yeah
you want to give it a number to it what
what sort of numbers should we give to
the pain that the kids feel because
they're actually being deprived of
affection we were not even worrying
about fairness at this point just the
fact that they won't you know they need
affection and they're not getting what
kind of number yeah let's call it a
seven and we have three kids
we'll leave the parents out of it just
to keep it simple
we have hit hey the kid see ya will make
kid a the favored kid so kid B and kid
see I already have - sentence so there
that's on the side of pain now the other
kid is getting a lot of affection so if
we're doing kind of a balance sheet like
this how much more affection are the
game let's say well it's a positive 7
they're getting we're getting the
infection if the other kids are already
it's ready to look like a bad deal isn't
it
overall now let's add in the extra thing
due to unfairness everybody in the
situation knows it's unfair does that
bother people how much pain should we
say it's caused by that 5 okay so minus
5 minus 5 if you think kid a feels the
same sense of unfairness to it maybe
less because they're not so directly
affected let's say they're not they're
oblivious everybody's so nice and this
house
in fairness conflicts produces conflict
between the kids how should we should we
value that that might actually be a
positive maybe maybe the other kids that
are on on the short end of the stick you
actually feel a little bit better when
they're in conflict with theirs
should we give that a positive value
what do you think where should we give
everybody a negative value
what would you say how do you feel more
confident when you get in conflict with
here your siblings is it all painful to
you or do you feel good about some okay
so we can actually split that into two
things let's say we give it a positive
know how much positive sorry it's a kid
kid be a kid see for like you know
sticking it to the favorite and just in
the present there's enough to outweigh
the infection they're not gonna know so
something was two or three okay and then
of course the kid a doesn't really like
it let's say they let's say they really
don't like and now long-term you're
right so let's say there's long term
negative effects for all of them so we
get that a tube as well - to what about
the long-term consequences for the kids
the kids who are treated without
affection are unlocked probably gonna
have worse outcomes right how should we
value that
is that so good night more than the
immediate loss of affection so let's say
- 9 and you know we know this actually
buy all these sociological studies that
you know for instance daughters need
fathers involved in their life and not
just sitting there in the chair but
actually actively engaged and sons to a
somewhat lesser extent you know their
social scientific research about this
what about kid age if they're getting a
tons of affection probably things should
turn out better for them shouldn't they
so look let's say it's it's positive
let's say it's positive 18 in actually
outweighs enough now and I know we could
go a lot further with this but I just
want to do this but we can look at it
overall how do things turn out for this
kid overall well positive 16 so actually
it's a winning proposition for that kid
to get more affection isn't it if it was
if they were just deciding on their
basis the way kids often do ya love me
forget them what about these other jets
let me tally it up is tonight cancel
each other out that eight negative
seventeen seventy it's worse slightly
worse for either one of these two kids
in the long run than it is for this kit
and there's two of these kids only one
of this kid so it ends up you know
saying you shouldn't do that you
shouldn't be unfair in the way that you
you apportion your affection you
shouldn't play favorites from
utilitarian perspective now here's where
it gets kind of interesting though what
if you switch things around and you had
two favorites and one kid it was like
the bad kid of the family
got no affection this was picked up
let's say that numbers are exactly the
same so that it turns out positive 16
positive 16 negative 17 then it starts
to look like an S positive utility it
doesn't it starts to look like that
would be an okay thing to do now you
could also compare that against you know
like treating all the kids the same and
you didn't if they let you have some
sort of baseline for that as well but
you see one of the the issues here with
utilitarianism if you start changing
these numbers if some things do affect
some people more and some people less
then the the solution can end up
changing to something that could be yeah
you probably shouldn't do it and turn
into yeah we should do it because it
generates more pleasure than pain
overall for the community of people
involved so there's there's a lot of
issues with with doing things this way
like I said though it does have the
benefit of being fairly easy to predict
doesn't that you could actually turn
everything into numbers are these
numbers perfect accurate representations
of what these hypothetical children
would feel probably not but could we
make them better do you think we did
some scientific studies came in
motivation wondered that we could so
this is one way in which we can we can
try to calculate pleasures and pains